[Music]
evening everyone welcome to the next
revolution i'm steve hilton this is the
home of positive populism pro worker pro
family pro community and especially
pro america how can a u.s president make
a major announcement about crime and not
propose a single thing
that would actually help solve the
problem for the long term
tolerance for gun dealers who willfully
violate
key existing laws and regulations five
new strike forces
to crack down illegal gun trafficking
more guidance on
how they can use the 350 billion dollars
nationally that the
american rescue plan has available
doubles funding for the gun violence
research
at the cdc and the national institutes
of health
the nih
he's still awake he barely was
technocratic
bureaucratic basically admitting how
bloated his blue state bailout was in
the first place
but above all just a predictable
playbook of a political lifer propped up
by a mediocre
unimaginative team announce some
initiatives shuffle some money from
one centralized scheme to another
distract and deflect from the disastrous
results of your own policies
for a year instead of fighting crime
they've been fighting the police
defunding
disrespecting demoralizing and now it's
not just aoc and the looney left the
biden administration is just as guilty
siding with far left activists pushing
not police reform
but police retreat anti-police witch
hunts targeting entire forces
undermining law enforcement making
cities more dangerous under biden the
democrats
police morale has hit an all-time low
officers resigning in protest taken away
from the places that need the most even
biden supporters are sounding the alarm
listen to tom friedman the new york
times
the very people the left claim to speak
for terrorized by gang shootouts
a nine-year-old girl killed by a stray
bullet while jumping on a trampoline a
nine-year-old girl killed on a
trampoline
think what that does to the well-being
of that community not just the
anguish of the victims family and
friends but the fear it creates
fear that anything could happen anywhere
any moment fear of
going outside fear of being on the
street fear of jumping on a trampoline
that's what you've done biden and aoc
and all the rest of you with your cold
ideological detached from reality defund
dogma
what wicked inhuman cruelty all the
while
posing as the allies of black
communities here's what an actual black
community leader thinks of that
quote for the last year i and my
neighbors have watched black mothers
react with incredulity
when their child is killed in community
violence and not by a white cop
their tragedies do not trigger city-wide
protest rallies people don't say their
child's name
this is a crisis created by democrats
just like they created the border crisis
and just like the border crisis they
talk about
tackling the root causes but do nothing
about them
on crime they instead glom onto a
cynical political tactic blame guns
half of biden's remarks were about guns
of course shootings are a big and
horrible part of biden's crime surge
up 73 percent in los angeles 90 in
minneapolis
166 in new york city across the country
the worst in decades
but this is not just about guns
carjackings
thefts hate crimes are on the rise
across the country
violent crime too on top of last year's
explosion homicides up another
24 so far this year and that's the
average
in oakland it's up 314
completely out of control and then the
everyday collapse of a sense of decency
and
order much of that not even captured
in the crime statistics the feeling of
unease
anxiety fear when people know that
violent aggressive lawless behavior
won't even be challenged
let alone punished where is all this
happening
mostly in cities run by democrats
the short-term cause is obvious what do
you expect if you attack the police and
take them off the streets if you
abolish cash bail and turn the justice
system into a revolving door
when the police retreat the criminals
and thugs and vandals advance
but it goes deeper than that why do
people behave this way
what has happened to the boundaries
self-imposed boundaries of
decent behavior that are the foundation
of a civilized society
we've seen a collapse of decency
self-respect and order
that is not inevitable it's not a
necessary byproduct of progress it's the
predictable
byproduct of progressive policies and
values
what do you think will happen if you
raise generation after generation of
boys without fathers
a prominent black commentator put it
well a few years ago
studies show that lack of a male role
model is an express train
right to prison and the cycle continues
so please
black folks as i said if this doesn't
apply to you i'm not talking to you
pay attention to and think about
what has been presented in recent
history as acceptable behavior
pay close attention to the hip-hop and
rap culture that many of you
embrace a culture that glorifies
everything i just mentioned
thug and reprehensible behavior a
culture
that is making a lot of people rich just
not you
and it's not going to
of course he's right but the party he
supports
has been pushing a policy agenda and a
cultural crusade that takes america in
the opposite direction
attacking family stability with
misguided welfare programs
the premature sexualization of children
the devaluation of
parenting into a free and easy lifestyle
choice instead of the most profound
and rewarding blessing and
responsibility
for two people to undertake together
trapping kids in chaotic union-run
schools that fail to instill
any sense of responsibility or
discipline let alone an education
everywhere you look in places run by
democrats you see the root causes of
crime
made worse not better we have to turn
things around yes
that means supporting our brave police
officers not undermining them
as i've often said police reform not
police retreat
but that's not enough we need long-term
change
a social revolution and conservatives
can
lead it because it is our ideas that
work school choice
strong families a society with more
respect
discipline decent values that's what
this country needs
not the pathetic superficial
grandstanding we got this week which
proved beyond reasonable doubt
that the last person who's going to fix
biden's crime crisis
is biden himself follow us at steve
hilton x and at next rev fnc and share
this message
when we post it joining us now